okay wonderful
all right um welcome everyone to ddps
uh seminar um people introduce our
invited speakers let's go over uh some
rules and logistics as usual
first of all please mute yourself during
the talk unless you have questions
if you have questions you are welcome to
mute yourself and ask those questions
otherwise please use chat room to post
your questions so that we
can address them in q a session at the
end
second today's ddps seminar is open to
external audiences
therefore no classified discussion is
allowed
so please watch out finally the talk
today will be recorded and uploaded
in our youtube channel okay that's about
it
now let me introduce our speaker today
it is an
honor to host jara who
is an assistant professor in the
department of aerospace and mechanical
engineering
at the university of notre dame
he received his phd in computational and
mathematical engineering from stanford
university in 2016
i happened to be at the same phd program
and there was your overlap with matt and
when i was
you know with matt at stanford
he was really really smart student
student and
and also he was really really hard
working person
i mean i i know that from from my
experience with him
and obviously naturally
he accomplished a lot
and he was a lewis w
alvarez postdoctoral fellow in the
department of
of mathematics at the lawrence berkeley
national lab from 2016 to 2018
and um you mad you got
the only courier overlord from samia
right like
air force yeah yeah and he's the
recipient of the early career
uh award from air force and his research
interests include high order methods for
computational physics
pde constraint optimization model
reduction computational methods
for resolving shocks and discontinuities
and multi-scale
methods okay today matt will present
model reduction of convection dominated
partial differential equations
via optimum optimization based implicit
feature tracking
which is a great interest to us so
please
enjoy and expect a wonderful
talk from matt now without further ado
let me uh pass the button to
matt by asking one random questions as
usual
um okay today's random question is
what is your favorite tv show
my favorite tv show um
do i have to answer that now or answer
at the end
you answer right now and then and then
well you you need a time to think about
it
uh i don't know yeah i i was a big game
of thrones fan when it was uh
especially during the earlier season so
i guess i'll i'll say game of thrones
it's hbo so i don't know if that counts
as tv or not but i'll go with that one
so
okay that's that's less to meet answer
thank you matt
it's all yours all right sounds good
thank you very much for the introduction
young two and the invitation to uh to
talk here so
i'm gonna be talking about model
reduction of convection dominated flow
specifically
and the obviously the the interesting
conv and convection dominant flows is
that they arise everywhere in
engineering analysis and design
specifically especially when you have uh
you know fluids and fluid flows
i'm in an aerospace department i spend
most of my time thinking about aerospace
applications
so these problems are obviously
everywhere in these in these fields
and um these really constitute some of
the most
challenging simulations that we do as
computational physicists because
they have you know very strong shock
waves they have they can potentially
have turbulence associated with them
if you're in very high speed regimes you
can have to account for
chemical interactions and ionization
they can lead to very complex and very
computationally
demanding simulations so that's where if
we want to use these for
to drive optimization or uncertainty
quantification it just becomes
impractical and that's where kind of
model reduction comes in
and unfortunately when you try to apply
up model reduction to these kinds of
problems
they face serious limitations so i have
a little
you know kind of probably many people
have seen a little demos like this and
because this is a fairly hot topic now
but i'm going to do it again just to
demonstrate
the point here is that you have we can
boil this down to a very simple 1d
problem
so we we take a um a we solve our cfd
problem and get one snapshot
we solve it we change the parameter in
some way that that discontinuity moves
and now we would like to approximate
something that's in between them
now this is something that we would hope
that we can do we you know sample our
very expensive high fidelity model
on on the end points of some parameter
configuration
and you would like to get it in between
and unfortunately if you're just going
to be doing linear combinations of these
black curves
the the best that you can do is this you
know jagged staircase
approximation which i think regardless
of whether you're an engineer a
mathematician or anyone i think we can
all agree that this is a pretty crappy
approximation that we're not going to be
happy with
so this essentially is the issue and
this comes up as the slowly decaying
coleman roth in with
you add enough samples in here um
between these two
black curves and you're going to
eventually get a decent approximation
but you need a bunch of them
um so that's that's the fundamental
problem and this is what i'm going to
be introducing methods to address in
this talk
but before i do that i'm actually going
to spend for the first half of the talk
talking about
a problem that is essentially the exact
same problem in a different context
and one of my solutions to that and then
ported over to the model reduction
setting
so if we look at this exact same problem
arises when we look at just standard
finite element based discretizations of
the same kinds of problems these
convection-dominated problems
so i'm going to do the same thing we
have a mesh a 1d mesh that consists of
two elements
and here's our basis now before our
basis was these nice global basis
functions but in the final setting we
have these
local potentially high order polynomial
basis functions you want to
approximate a discontinuity now and
everything is fine in the first element
but then you get these oscillations in
the second element
it's a terrible approximation first off
and the oscillations can actually cause
the
codes to crash so this is a problem
that's been around forever in cfd
so this the way that people deal with
this is there's there's a number of
different ways
one is that you do something called
limiting where you say i don't want to
allow all those high order oscillations
so i'm just going to
crush them and reduce this to a first
order approximation here
and that's fine it addresses the kind of
the overshoot undershoot issue but it's
obviously a pretty crappy approximation
still
so you have to add in some mesh
refinement near the discontinuity
and you can get a decent approximation
the downside of this is that we just
went the opposite direction of model
reduction instead of trying to make
things cheaper we made it more expensive
to have to refine
um in these regions so another proc
another approach is artificial viscosity
say i don't want to deal with
discontinuities
i would much rather deal with with steep
features so we're going to replace the
red
with this steep feature magenta curve
and try to approximate that
your oscillations are reduced still not
a great approximation so you still have
to um
enrich with the refinements of your of
your mesh again kind of going the
opposite problem from reduction
so another class of methods that i've
been working a lot on is called shock
track
and the really the fundamental idea
behind shock tracking is that
we have a feature in the solution that
feature right here is a discontinuity
that same feature exists on our basis
that's that we have a discontinuity that
we can support between these two
elements
the problem is the features in the wrong
spot it's the exact same problem that we
had
in the model reduction setting our basis
actually had that shock that we needed
in it but it was in the wrong spot and
when we tried to use it as in our basis
it you know didn't give us a good
approximation same
issue happens here so the idea behind
shock tracking is that if i can deform
my mesh
such that the interface between the
elements lies at that discontinuity
now the discontinuity in my basis is
aligned with the discontinuity of my
solution
and you can just nail this nail the um
the pretty much the exact solution in
this case
now if we have if it's not piecewise
constant you won't necessarily get the
exact solution but you get
approximations on really coarse meshes
so
to kind of take the motivation for this
kind of tracking method further because
that's the idea that we're going to be
employing in the model reduction setting
is that one of the benefits of this is
that you can actually recover
optimal convergence rates of your
underlying scheme everyone
probably is familiar with it if you do a
finite element method you're going to
get these order h to the p
plus one um optimal convergence rates
but that only is for smooth solutions
but if you actually track the
discontinuity the finite element basis
does not see
the the discontinuity at all you're just
using those higher order basis functions
to approximate
away from the discontinuity and you can
recover recover optimal convergence
rates
another kind of taking this a step
further is that why we actually care
about doing this in the high order
setting
and i really think about modern
reduction as kind of like the ultimate
high order method because with higher
order methods we try to make
try to make coarser meshes that have
inside
each of these elements these larger
elements higher order basis functions so
we hopefully can reduce the overall
number of degrees of freedom
roms take that to the extreme where you
really have just one element that has
all these global basis functions in it
so it's it's kind of in the same spirit
here
anyway but the the point is that when
you do shock tracking
with higher order methods there's an
exaggerated benefit so what i did is i
ran two
two studies here first one was i just
used the standard kind of shock
capturing method
with very aggressive aggressive uh a
mesh adaptation in the vicinity of the
shock
and that's what these red curves are the
dash curves are the solid curves are
when we do shock tracking and these are
for diff the different colors mean
different polynomial degrees
so if you look at the difference between
the dash and the solid black line
there's there's an improvement for
for doing a tracking approach but it's i
mean it's not ridiculous
but if you start to look for p2 or p3
you're talking about five
six orders of magnitude improvement so
this this this idea of tracking
really helps you a ton in the high order
setting
whereas it helps in the low order
setting but it the benefits are
exaggerated and higher percent
and to take this kind of a step further
is that if you just look at the
solutions you get by tracking
the um discontinuities i mean this is
supersonic flow over a cylinder
and if we use a p2 mesh which we have
right here i mean you can get
basically the exact solution um with
with less than 50 elements
whereas if you're going to be doing this
with shock capturing you would have tons
of refinements
around the um the shock here and you
would have thousands or maybe even tens
of thousands of elements
for a um for a um disc
this kind of problem so that's that's my
kind of pitch for
why shock tracking is kind of a relevant
thing to do but the the
the next question should be well why do
people not really use it in most of
modern cfd and the the answer is that
it's
pretty hard to do when you have complex
problems so you have this little
scramjet here
you have some some usually hypersonic
flow would come in here or some high
mass flow would come in here
and you get all these shocks that bounce
around and you'd have to somehow align
your mesh with
all this these these shocks and you
don't know them by the way you don't
know where the shocks are they're a
function the solution
you know the boundaries but you don't
know the internal boundaries like that
so this is so problems like this have
been kind of where shock
tracking has kind of not been able to
make a big impact
and this has really been where i've been
putting a lot of my research effort in
the last few years is developing methods
that can specifically overcome this
difficulty associated with
explicitly trying to match these unknown
discontinuity services
okay so that's that's my overall pitch
for shock tracking so what i'm going to
do for the rest of my talks i'm going to
spend about
about 15 ish minutes talking about our
approaches
for actually doing shock tracking
without even talking about romps
and then we're going to uh i'm going to
bring that into the model reduction
setting and connect it to
to what we're doing so that's that's the
kind of the outline
of of the rest of the talk here so so
looking at this the shock tracking
method that we've been developing
as i mentioned the goal really is to
align your
uh mesh the phases of your mesh with
your discontinuities
and so we can see another example here
of if you don't do any alignment and you
want to represent this piecewise
constant function
you don't do such a good job but once
you once you align it it's you can nail
it with a really coarse mesh
so the the method that we've been
developing is based on a dg
discoverization
because for two reasons the first is
that we have these intra element jumps
so if we get those faces aligned
the jumps capture the discontinuity and
then um they're high order so i tried to
make the case for high order um at a few
minutes ago
now the innovation of the approach here
and this is exactly the same thing that
we're going to be putting into the model
reduction setting
is that we don't treat this as a mesh
generation problem
even though it technically is because
you need a mesh that conforms to all
these interior
shock boundaries we don't treat it that
way what we do is we create a mesh
that we you know doesn't know anything
about the shock just comes out of
unstructured mesh generation
and then we set up an optimization
problem that
drives the the mesh toward one that
aligns with shocks
that's that's the difference here so we
don't think about this as mesh
generation we think about it as
optimization
and then we we come up with solvers to
solve these optimization points
so to see what that looks like we're
going to start with just the kind of
formulation
we have some sort of a conservation line
i write it as steady state if you want
time dependent you can write it in a
space-time
setting and use slabs we then discretize
with dg
in this in this case and we get this
kind of standard gg form with your
numerical flux function in here if we
write this in algebraic setting we get
this this
fully discrete residual which is going
to depend on your fully discrete
coefficient vector of of your flip the
container flow field
as well as the nodes of your mesh
because we need that
to explicitly show up on a residual
because we're going to start moving
these around
we also introduce this thing i call
capital r which is where we actually
enrich our test functions so so p prime
is the polynomial degree of your test
functions we take p
prime to be p plus one in the definition
of r so we
are we're bumping up the number of test
functions
that we have per element and we're going
to use this to define our objective
function
that is in our optimization problem
so here is the the formulation we have
very standard
um pde constrained optimization look to
it something that means who worked on
way back in
in grad school a bunch of different
applications and um so here's
here's what it looks like so our
constraint is is the dg equations the
the standard
galerkin dg equations um with with p
the the test and trial space equal
degrees um and the reason we put that
there is because we want this method to
inherit the properties that we like
about dg
it's higher order accuracy it's
consistency conservation all those
beautiful properties
we want so by putting them as our
constraint here we're going to to get
them
then our objective function is going to
be composed of two terms the first one
or the second one is going to be this r
mesh term
which is just kind of the obvious
requirement that we don't want our
mesh to degrade we want to retain a
fairly high quality mesh
and then this other one is this enriched
residual where we've added on these test
functions
the idea is that they will penalize
non-physical oscillations that would
arise
from solving on a non-aligned mesh and
then drive the mesh toward one that is
aligned
so that's that's what the the
optimization problem is now we can't
actually going back we can't
solve this using what people would call
a reduced space approach that's kind of
the go-to
in pde constraint optimization you would
want to like at least what i would want
to given my background pd constraint
optimization would be to
update the mesh solve the dg equations
and then plug that in here and you can
have an unconstrained optimization
problem
which are easy to work with you can get
gradients and stuff using adjoint
methods
but that won't work in the setting
because we cannot solve
this dg equation for any mesh if the
mesh is not aligned we can get these
oscillations that cause it to crash
so we can't use reduced space approaches
so we do a full space approach
which means we lump u and x into a um
a combined vector that i call z and we
update that whole thing
together until we converge to a solution
of the optimization problem
and to do this we use sequential
quadratic programming so we said
every iteration delta z is computed as
the solution of a quadratic
approximation to our original pde
constraint optimization problem
and then um the so there's a lot of
details that go in here we need some
approximation to
the hessian of the lagrangian and we
choose the search direction using a line
search technique
i'm not going to go into the details of
that in this talk but this is this is
essentially how we do that
so to look at a few of how this works we
start with a very simple application
which is just advection in a oh he's not
going to work you can hear me
wait a second accept
okay there we go so we have a very
simple application where we have just
advection in a um 2d
domain it's a step function over here
and the vection field is pointing to the
upper left
and you can see i just showed the the
shock tracking iterations we start from
just a solution that is
a mesh that knows really nothing about
the discontinuity
first order finite volume approximation
to start and then here's
where um how the shock tracking approach
works
so we can um see that we get really
rapid convergence to the
optimal solution newton-like convergence
less than about 10 iterations
and we get to essentially machine
tolerance and the thing to note here is
that this is where you can see the full
space
a method in action because the residual
the little r the dg residual
is only zero i mean it's technically
zero at the beginning because we started
with the the first
the finite volume solution but um we
it's only it's not
zero any until the very end that's all
you're guaranteed with the with full
space matches
methods if you were going to be doing a
reduced space method
you would be having this this little r
zero the whole time
right so that's that's the kind of how
these approaches work but again for this
problem
the reduced space approach would work
because it's a linear direction it's not
going to go
unstable and blow up on you but um it
won't work for more complicated problems
like
that involve the oil equations same kind
of problem but now we have a spatially
varying invection field
um pretty pretty um rapid convergence to
the solution here
can do it in 3d um to uh to to get these
kind of uh
tracked fields even with if you have you
know these curved tetrahedra elements
so um to look at a more interesting
example it's one d now but it's it's the
euler equations
um where we have flow through a nozzle
um
and this is the density distribution
that you get first thing we do is we
solve this with shock capturing we put
down a mesh that has 50 elements
and we um refine uh and and we get this
um solution that's pretty much perfect
everywhere except for the shock region
your approximate discontinuity with this
steep um steep gradient we're going to
do shock tracking now
we're going to put down a much coarser
mesh and we're going to solve the shock
tracking equation and you're going to
eventually get these
as your inter-element boundaries and you
can see you've got one that perfectly
aligns
with the jump here and the yellow is
which lies right on top of the black is
the approximation and then looking at
convergence rates of this you can see
that we actually recover again these
optimal
convergence rates up to p5 whereas
if you do shock capturing that the error
is going to be dominated right at the
shock
and it's going to be limited to
essentially first order convergence
so that's that's again the benefit of
doing the shock tracking approach
now um one thing that i haven't
mentioned yet and this is going to be
important not just in this setting but
really important also in the rom setting
is that i can't optimize the nodes like
i said
so so far if you optimize the nodes
directly all the nodal coordinates
you're going to have nodes on boundaries
they're going to fly off boundaries as
the optimizer
starts to try to figure things out
things out and now you've just changed
your problem
and it's essentially meaningless so we
have to essentially enforce the
boundaries
remain boundary the same boundaries that
they started as
dirt throughout the whole mesh motion
process so to do this what we do is we
introduce this mapping fee
which is going to guarantee that the
boundaries are preserved so instead of
optimizing
directly over the nodal coordinates
we're going to introduce a collection of
unconstrained degrees of freedom
that i can freely change and tweak and
however i want to
and then plug that into my mapping and
my mapping is going to output me
something that
will conform to my original boundaries
so then it the modification of the
tracking problem becomes very simple
i just everywhere that i had x i replace
it with v of y
and i optimize over y so to see what
this looks like i mean if
if we go down to this very simple mesh
down here all of these blue nodes are
interior i can move those in x and y
however i want to
and you can see that like they can move
freely in x and y
but for example on this bottom boundary
you can only move an x if you move it
all in y you're changing that bottom
boundary
so that's where your unconstrained
figure of freedom would be your x
coordinate
and the then the you would use this
mapping to determine what the y
coordinate has to be
similarly here you you can't this is not
just move x or y you have to move let's
say pick one of them
and then the for example the y
coordinate then would be given in
terms of the x coordinates and then for
example at
intersections of boundaries those notes
can't move at all so
this can all be all of these cases can
very easily be worked out from just
looking at the normals
of the boundaries in the case where all
of your boundaries are planar
when your boundaries are curved you have
to actually know the curvature the
expression for the
analytical expression for the boundaries
so for here again we can
still move all these nodes it's not like
they have to remain frozen but they need
to slide along
their appropriate boundary anyway this
is something you can do we have an
archive paper on this um that we just
put out a month or so ago
that can be used to do this
so just to show how this method works on
a few um a few examples
i'll show mach 2 flow over a cylinder
and we already kind of saw this one in a
half domain earlier
we can do mach 3 flow over the cylinder
using the same starting mesh
kind of shows this is kind of robust to
meshes whereas if you're doing this with
shock
capturing you would need to have
different refinement regions about these
two different areas to be able to um
really be able to change your mock
number like this we can do mock four
flow over this um
curved cylinder thing sorry over this
curved square thing we can do some uh
transonic
cases this one you have to actually be
able to slide along this curved boundary
of the noc airfoil
and then kind of exact same mesh we went
from mach 0.8 to mach point uh mach 2
um we do uh uh supersonic flow to to
align with the
shocks there so um i'm gonna skip over a
few
of the details we have to be able to
allow elements to collapse out of the
mesh
because it's if when you have really
complicated problems it's hard to
actually just move nodes around and get
things to align
so that we have to be able to to remove
elements we do very simple
operations called element collapse where
we essentially say we have a an element
that's
an edge that's too short so we collapse
that edge and
and remove it from the mesh that's the
only mesh operation that's
that's topological in nature that we
have to do um
so let me skip over a few of these
things just because i don't want to
spend too much time on this
the other practical consideration i have
to do is that when you have high order
approximations you can have oscillations
that arise so this is just an example of
an oscillation that can kind of that can
arise when you're doing this tracking
if you just leave it alone it's going to
lead to terrible sqp
search directions and this is one of the
this if you have this
um as the state of your mesh and your
solution
this will be your next iteration even
after doing a fancy
line search on an l1 merit function so
it really the oscillations spread to
neighboring elements
screws up your mesh it's just not good
so you just have to sit around hope that
those elements kind of get collapsed out
so what we do instead is we just say i
don't want to deal with these things so
we go through and find the elements that
are oscillating
using a very standard indicator and we
reinitialize them to their
an average value and then we continue
the sqp iterations from there
and it has a pretty big impact if we
don't do us
uh reinitialization we get stuck here
with these oscillations
and inside these elements that don't go
away and then you don't get things
tracked
at the the wherever they arise
but if we do the reinitialization like i
just mentioned those just get
pushed out of the solution in it and it
does not impede tracking
so um then to just last thing i want to
say on this before i show a couple more
examples is that
how do we actually get an initial guess
right we're doing
non-convex opt pde constraint
optimization
so the initial guesses are important so
what we do is we
um the mesh we don't really have we
don't know where the internal boundaries
are so really the best we can do is
whatever
the mesh that comes out of the mesh
generator whether that's a structured
mesh
because it's a really really simple
domain or it's an unstructured mesh
whatever that is
that's what we use as an initial guess
for the mesh our solution
there's we tried a bunch of fancy things
here the one that
turned out to be the best was just use a
p0dg solution or a first order finite
volume solution
so that's why for that burgers equation
i just showed this is where
we start and one of the things these
robustness measures the element
collapses and the initializations i've
done
is that we do not need to use homotopy
in the polynomial degree
before we had these we had to start at
p1 and then go to p2 and
slowly ramp up but now we just whatever
polynomial degree we want
we go straight there from this
approximation so whether it's p1 where
we have these faceted approximations
for p4 we we don't do any sort of
homotopic
okay so just to show last couple last
examples so here's the um
here's just a standard sod shock tube we
start with just a jump in the solution
and it when you have these waves a shock
a contact and a rare faction
that emanate from that point so this is
what's just what the solution looks like
but um if we we solve this with shock
tracking we're going to use a space time
formulation as i mentioned before
and here's what our solution looks like
the tracking iterations look like
you see that initially the shock was
tracked pretty quickly
then you get the contact next and then
you even get the head and the tail of
the rarefaction
that tracks so it's not only
discontinuities
that get tracked it's also steep
features all right sorry
it's also um non-smooth features
including jumps and derivatives
even when the solution is continuous
and then there's the solution without
the without the mesh um and then you can
see slices um from the tracking align
pretty well with the the exact solution
so a more interesting example and
actually one of my favorite ones that
we've done so far is 2d steady euler
equations flow over a diamond
and we'll run this one and you see
what's going to happen here is that we
have a
shock that's going to come up it's going
to reflect and it's going to
intersect with the shock down here which
is going to intersect again
and by doing this full space
approach where we just iterate both mesh
and the solution together
we can get you know fairly complex shock
interactions
um out of this and we can get them
tracked
and then without the mesh you have this
uh this approximation
so taking that same example a little bit
more um extreme higher mach number more
complex geometry
we kind of see similar behavior we can
get the internet the intersections and
the reflections and the curve
um the curve shocks um out of this takes
a few more iterations requires a bit
finer mesh in this case
um but but uh kind of eventually
converges to uh
uh a reasonable reasonable line
reasonably aligned mesh
okay last example um before i get back
into uh the rom stuff
is we're gonna look at a 3d problem um
this is the steady euler equations flow
over a cylinder here's our mesh that's
only 500 tetrahedral elements
we're using polynomial degree 2 for the
solution and 2 for the mesh
and this is where we start i mean you
can tell that this is almost a comically
bad
solution on this course of a mesh when
you use first order finite volumes
and then after about 30 tracking
iterations um we get
this uh this this bow shock track pretty
well and i'm
now going to just look at the shock
layer removing all of the constant flow
outside of it
and you can see that you know we've got
hybrid approximation the boundary of
course but that's just from mesh
generation
but we have the high order curved
approximations of the actual bow shock
that comes from the optimization
approach okay so that was
it on my on my kind of my first part on
implicit shock tracking we formulated as
an optimization problem over
the dg solution and mesh coordinates we
get these accurate solutions on course
meshes and optimal convergence rates
and then the high order methods benefit
uh they exaggerate the benefits of
tracking discontinuities
and that's the these kind of takeaways
are what we're going to pour it into the
modern reduction
setting so if we go back to our example
um i can
play the first couple things again or so
this is this is where we're at when we
we started is that we're trying to
approximate the blue with just the
the black snapshots and we got the red
so what we're going to do now is we're
going to now apply some of these same
ideas we want to
deform the domain i've been talking
about as a mesh but it's really an
underlying
domain deformation to align the snapshot
the shock and the snapshots
with the discontinuity okay
now the idea is that within the dg
setting all of our elements are in some
sense created equal and they go to piece
them together to
cover to cover the full mesh but in this
setting each one of our snapshots
is covering the full mesh and we kind of
want them to work together so
you know which one should i push i pull
this one over here should i pull this
one over here
if you do that approach you're only
going to be able to use one of them and
it takes away kind of the point of the
training
so what we do instead is we map all of
these
to a common reference domain
it's going to be a different mapping
applied to each one but they're going to
and then we're going to do it such that
all of these shocks discontinuities
whatever
align with each other in a
fixed reference domain using the same
ideas of an underlying mesh staff
a domain deformation in this
domain there is no convection-dominated
nature of the solution we've removed
that
so now we're going to approximate the um
the the shock using these basis
functions and
it's not moving now so everything's kind
of in the right spot and then we just
push it back to
where it was in the physical domain so
that's that's the
the idea behind the approach and that's
really how it's gonna con that's how it
connects to what we did with the
implicit shock tracking
for dg so so to take this idea a little
bit farther what i have done is i've
just plotted one single
basis function that's going to be
sitting in the in a reference domain
here just some cut off gaussian thing
and then i have some smooth mapping and
by composing these things
together you can move this shock
anywhere you want to
that's kind of what i've already
demonstrated in some of the previous
examples
but you can that's that's what this
bottom example here is by just different
values of tau
you can put this shock anywhere you want
it in the domain
with everything being smooth
this works in higher dimensions too i
just i have some sort of a solution here
that's got it's it's kind of centered
in the in the middle of this domain um
and then i'm showing
some sort of underlying mesh we apply
some smooth domain deformation to it and
we can move the peak
over to the right right so that's kind
of where we can we can do this
these domain deformations can can move
features around
all right so now to actually start
formulating this at a you know more
detailed level
we're going to now write down our
physical domain omega
as the results of a mapping applied to a
fixed reference domain
so the idea is that my conservation law
is going to be posed
in my physical domain omega whatever the
domain is that you care about
but we don't want to solve it there
i want to solve it on a fixed reference
domain because in the in the setting
that i talked about where i'm going to
be applying a different
mapping to each of the snapshots that
means i'm solving
you know on different domains it's going
to be still the same boundary but the
interior is going to be
morphed in different ways um so i don't
i don't want to deal with that
so instead of this what we're going to
do is we're going to introduce a fixed
reference domain and we're going to
recast the conservation laws
on that reference domain that's that's
the the fundamental approach here
this is the exact same thing that we do
in the in the shock tracking setting
i just didn't really introduce it at
that level because it was not really a
necessary detail
here it's more of a necessary detail
okay so now here's the
the outline of the approach so that
we're gonna say that we're gonna have
we're to start with our discretization
um which is going to depend exactly the
same way it's going to be on our
high dimensional model solution u it's
going to depend on the coordinates of
our mesh and now we've added in some
sort of parameter
and um we're now going to but this is
all going to be
imposed in the reference domain so this
u
means the the state vector in the
reference domain x is the
the the mapping to the um the the
coordinates of the physical mesh etc
so our offline pin is it's going to fall
it's going to go as follows given some
collection of training parameters
we are going to determine our solution
and our reference domain as well as our
mapping
these are going to be tied to the the
current
parameter that we're looking at such
that the dominant features
align in the reference domain exactly
the way that my little schematic in the
beginning
we want them all to that feature to be
in the same spot
so we can apply we can compress the
snapshots and then we can do the
approximation of that domain and then
just push it back to the physical
so then the next thing is going to
compress the snapshots the the
compression is a lot more effective
when the there's there's not
discontinuities moving around
and then finally we're going to actually
reduce the mesh degrees of freedom
because in a rom setting
we don't want to have to move all of the
nodes of the mesh independently because
there's potentially a lot of them so we
want to um
reduce that and then last thing we're
going to do that's offline then online
we're going to give it a new parameter
we're going to determine the reduced
order state
and the reduced order mesh and then we
can just reconstruct our
our full mesh and state
um okay all right so here's what the
offline procedure looks like
so we're going to start by just um so
we're going to be given
the first whatever our first parameter
is we're going to just solve the dg
equations on that mesh
and we're going to to take our first
mesh
as our whatever our reference mesh was
so we don't need to do any kind of
anything fancy for the first parameter
it's just what we're using to
seed our iterations and then after that
we're going to solve something that
looks exactly like the shock tracking
problem
that i introduced 10 or 15 minutes ago
but it's going to still have your high
dimensional model
as a constraint here and you're going to
still have a mesh term out here
the one difference is that we're not
going to be minimizing this enriched
residual
which would it doesn't really have any
sensitivity to which
elements align with the shock we want to
make sure that all of these different
snapshots align in a reference
configuration
so what we're going to do is we're going
to use the the projection error
of the um the the projection error
essentially
onto this onto this basis because the
idea behind that would be that
um when the snapshots have their feature
aligned
the projection error will be smallest
and that's what that's what the
the kind of the idea behind behind using
this
and then we're just going to add on the
new solution to our basis
and then just keep going until we're
done and that's essentially the offline
procedure
so the reason again that we do this is
that i'm just going to do an example
before and after alignment before
alignment we have this is just a
different example now is that we have
some sort of diffusion there's some
steepening
and uh it's kind of waning shock that
forms here
if we use these snapshots and we look at
the first pod modes
here's what you get but then if you look
at the singular value decay
it's very slow this is the whole
chromograph in with
barrier that we we hear so much about
and if we look at the the number
of snapshots that are required to reduce
this to ten to the minus three ten to
the minus six or ten to minus nine
i mean it's it's a ton if you instead
you align these all into one spot
and then you do the the look at the
first pd mode you have that
dominant shock captured in your first
mode and your snapshots decay extremely
quickly
you get 10 to the minus 3 10 to the
minus 6 10 to the minus 9
and like 10 10 vectors here
so this is just more more motivation for
why we actually go through the pain to
do
the offline alignment in the first place
okay so then online the the problem is
going to look pretty
similar but now what we're going to be
doing is we're going to essentially just
we're given a new parameter and this
should be a mu star in here sorry
we're going to be minimizing our hdm
residual over
our reduced coordinates for
our solution as well as over our reduced
mesh
so people are familiar with model
reduction are used to seeing these kind
of minimization problems
but usually you're only over minim
you're usually only minimizing over the
rom state
we are simultaneously in the same spirit
as we did with shock tracking minimize
over the
state and the mesh and then we can of
course reconstruct
this we haven't we are working on this
now we don't have i don't have any
results in this paper about how to
extend this with high production
techniques
particularly fits well within the the
empirical quadrature type procedures
like ucsw and eqp um so
i want to just do one last quick example
on
what this approach kind of looks like in
a kind of very a very simplified setting
so to do that i'm going to introduce
a one-dimensional domain mapping so
here's my undeformed
here's my deformed and i'm going to take
everything just as linear combinations
between these two so this would be
my my mesh parameter s equals zero this
would be s equals one and then
everything would be in
you know s between zero and one would
give you intermediate deformation so
this would be s one half
now what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
here's my high dimensional solution
snapshot on the left
this is gonna be just comes from some
solution of some advection diffusion
configuration and then this is my
training one
single training point and what i want to
predict is this one where i've changed
some of the
um the flow directions uh parameters and
now the peak is concentrated here at the
right and i want to use this
one basis function to approximate
this configuration obviously with
standard model reduction it's not going
to be a great job because the peaks
aren't aligned but that's that's kind of
the point is to demonstrate what you get
by also optimizing over the mesh
so again if we do standard residual
minimization this is what you get
i'm showing the mesh here to show that
it's not deformed at all now if we also
do this implicit feature tracking where
we simultaneously optimize over the mesh
and the state you move the mesh to the
right and you move that peak over you
pull that peak over
now the more interesting thing is is
here is on these contours
so right here what i've done is i've
done the con i've drawn the contours
of the error with respect to the high
dimensional model
versus the reduced basis coefficient
because there's one of them right so 1d
with 1d basis as well as the domain
mapping because there's one that's why i
did i was insisting on 1d in both so i
could plot these
with contour plots and then over here i
did the exact same x and y coordinates
but here i'm applying the residual norm
so if we look at the right to start with
when you do standard
residual minimization over just the
states what you're doing is you're
freezing the domain mapping to be zero
and optimizing along only this line
and that minimum falls right here if you
expand your space and allow it to
optimize over the mesh you actually find
that the real minimum or the true
minimum in this expanded space lies way
over here
so now if we see what this looks like on
the error plot
you can see that you're by restricting
to this s equals zero line
you're stuck in a pretty high error
region
but by you know now residuals and errors
don't necessarily
they're not the same thing obviously so
we're not getting to a minimum of the
error
but it's falling in the low error region
of this um diagram which is really the
point of enriching
of expanding the space and optimizing
over both
okay so now we're gonna um look at two
examples the first one is a beautiful
example that
tommaso introduced in his 2020 paper
that's just a very nice parameterized
advection
um uh reaction equation where it's got
three parameters but the main parameter
is
in your flow direction it's what changes
the kind of the direction
of of your your primary steep
feature that you've got here so just
showed a few different um a few
different snapshots
and we're going to apply the implicit
tracking procedure to this
problem so the first thing that we're
going to look at is the snapshots that
we generate
so we generated a few um different
snapshots here this is just the
the one that we start with right that
reference configuration that we start
with
and then we have two different ones
based on whatever our primary
configurations
um were and you can see that if we're in
the physical domain you have your mesh
that's kind of moving around um this is
just kind of plotted to view the um
the so you can see what the domain
deformation looks like
but you have um here and then here you
can see how the the elements that were
originally aligned
now dip down to a line there or they dip
up to a line there
and then but but the key thing here is
that if we look at this in the reference
domain
that's what we have down here for each
of these snapshots and the primary
discontinuity
is always in the same spot or you know
roughly in the same spot
which is going to improve the
compressibility of the um
the snapshots now if we look at the pod
modes
the top is if you don't bother to do any
sort of alignment
and what you see is that these are the
first three pod modes all of the energy
of these modes is focused on trying to
advect that um that that feature
across the domain and that's where but
you don't get any of the really detail
elsewhere i mean it's some i guess but
it's not really the
it's it's much less dominant feature in
these basis functions
whereas if everything if that um feature
is not moving
all of the the higher order uh
the the higher order modes uh the higher
modes are going to
you know be focusing on these kind of
auxiliary uh features
and not having to worry about that main
uh discontinuity or its steep feature in
this case
so that's kind of the visual
representation of what we're trying to
do here now if we look at just a quick
little study so what i did here is i
just looked at a 1d parameter space by
freezing the second
third parameters and only varying this
more difficult parameter that that moves
the discontinuity around
my test set that i'm going to be
training i'm going to be testing both a
standard rom
and a rom with inflative feature
tracking on contains 100
samples in this one deep space and we
the error metric that i use is the
maximum error
out of all of those hundred test points
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
grow
my training set because the whole point
of trying to do this
is trying to use limited training
because i mean
to be honest if you wanted to do if you
didn't care about what the training cost
was
you don't really need to do any of this
because enough of taking enough
snapshots and you're eventually going to
get something that's okay
right so the whole point here is being
able to do this for limited training
sets
okay so if we so that's what we're doing
we're growing our training set from
containing one to two to three all the
way up to like 40 points
and what we see is that if the black is
the rom and the blue is the the implicit
feature tracking
that for you know really small training
sets like less than size 10 here
you know on the size one two three four
range and there's a big difference
or almost an organ of magnitude between
of reduction and error between the rom
and the rom with implicit feature
tracking and that you have diminishing
returns when you have large basis
functions as you'd expect because the
rom is starting if you're getting
you know a decent sampling of that
discontinuity now how it's moving around
and getting a pretty good approximation
so that's the
the first study that we ran here to see
the the kind of benefits of this
particularly in the limited training
regime
now if we look at another study where
we're actually opening up and
considering the whole 3d parameter space
now
and we're considering a five by five by
five sampling of that as our test set
and taking again the maximum error over
that if we do
a training set that only contains one
snapshot literally once one
point sampled from the very center of
that parameter domain you know
not going to expect too much out of this
because of how limited the training is
with just the standard rom your maximum
error is 59 but with the feature
tracking it's still
i would say unacceptably large at 26
percent but it's still a pretty dramatic
reduction down
now we do the next one where we just do
a two by two by two to give us eight
snapshots
then the rom is still at about 24 which
is
roughly what the implicit feature
tracking was at with only one snapshot
but the wrong with implicit feature
tracking for for the eight snapshots
goes down to
you know five-ish percent and you can
just see this was a kind of
representative
example we took this is the hdm solution
this is the rom where you see kind of
you don't get the discontinuity
it's kind of smeared over the the kind
of the range where it's varying
and then um the implicit feature
tracking removes that but it's not
perfect i mean you can see these
features down here certainly are not
being captured that well
even with the wrong with implicit future
tracking when you have you know limited
training
but you get the you get the primary the
dominant features out
all right so i'm just about out of time
so one last quick example which is just
transonic flow over a noc airfoil
so we're going to be this is where we're
actually going to combine implicit
feature tracking and implicit shock
tracking
um so that's where we're going to start
our our reference cfd solver is going to
be
implicit shock tracking so actually the
meshes that i'm going to be using here
are really course i only have actually
127 element mesh
but we'll see we'll look at the first
two these are going to be the snapshots
that we're going to get
with um with using this implicit feature
tracking
we have mach 0.8 here we have mach .87
here
and then we have a training
configuration which is mach .85
and um this is this is so this is our
online approximation and you know you
get a reasonably good approximation i
haven't compared to hdmi i'll do that in
a couple sites
um now if we look at without the the
mesh you can see what these um
these features look like the the shocks
are of you know varying position along
the airfoil and they extend a different
amount into the domain
before they become smooth um now if we
look in the reference domain kind of go
back and forth between those again so
this is in the physical domain if we
look in the reference domain
all of those shocks are kind of in the
same spot and you can see that better if
we look at slices of the solution
so in the physical domain we have this
shock as we you know change our mach
number is changing kind of all
all through here but if we then look at
these things in
in the reference domain boom all the
shocks line at this one spot
which is exactly what we wanted to
improve the compressibility
and approximation of these features and
just to completely avoid
any sort of staircase a staircase type
um
discontinuity approximation and then now
if we compare the implicit feature
tracking out the two training
configurations
as well as at the um the the online
configuration
you can see you know pretty pretty good
um agreement between
between the two the blue is the the hdm
which comes from implicit shock tracking
and the the yellow is the wrong with
implicit feature tracking
okay so that is um pretty much
everything i wanted to say so just to
summarize
we introduced this uh implicit feature
tracking um which is really
i think of as implicit shock tracking
move imported into the model reduction
setting
um we it leads to we align features in
snapshots to improve
their compressibility we do residual
minimization over
simultaneously same way that we do with
shock tracking simultaneously over the
state the reduced
basis state as well as the domain
mapping and then this can lead to
accurate solutions for shock dominated
problems
with limited training with that i'll
just
i just want to acknowledge my funding as
well as my students
here at notre dame tens has done a lot
of great work on shock tracking and mars
has done a lot of great work on the rom
implicit feature tracking so with that
um thank you very much for your
attention and be happy to take any
questions
thank you thank you so much it was a
wonderful talk i
i loved it um okay thank you so much for
great talk matt let's have a q a session
yes yes there's a club from grace
all right um okay
uh the questions are coming in in
chat room okay first question from henry
thanks for the talk do you know if this
technique has been applied to modeling
dislocation dynamic in solids where in
the dislocation points you have
diverging strain fields or in your
opinion when looking at the problems
such as
uh such high resolution one might as
well just do
automatic molecular dynamics
optimistic optimistic yeah yeah um
so i haven't really done much on
applying these kind of techniques to
anything in
solids yet um it's something i'm
interested in doing
um but i haven't i haven't really i
haven't done anything there yet so i
really don't know what to expect out of
it
um but it would be um it would be
interesting and i do think that it
especially the implicit shock tracking
approach as a
if you start with implicit shock
tracking it's very natural to build on
this implicit feature tracking rom
approach on top of it that's kind of why
i did that for the
the airfoil the this this naka airflow
case
um so yes and as far as um you know when
looking at such high relation resolution
should you do atomistic molecular
dynamics
that that's a little bit beyond what i
can kind of i guess give a
recommendation on because i don't really
do any work and atomistic so
i'm probably i'm just going to probably
skip over that because i i just don't
really know
okay thank you uh next question is from
rahul i suppose this method uh
be expected to extend it to
be any problem where there might be a
sort of discontinuity in the
computational domain
please correct rahu if it's wrong
yeah no so that i i agree with you
actually i think that
because this idea is very pde agnostic
in some sense
where um we i mean i wrote this down
really
the kind of the point of departure was
the optimization formation minimize f
subject to you know r of u comma x
equals zero
so if you can kind of write your pde in
that form
um it it can be you know essentially you
would think you could
use this kind of an approach now of
course the details of of
and these objective functions should
should scale or should should extend is
at least in
i mean that ours are a little bit
tailored to find element settings but if
you're using a find element setting to
to do
you know these these types of
simulations it it should extend
i i haven't done them so i don't exactly
know what the
the issues would be that would arise but
um
you know at a high level the formulation
is not
really tied to um to to conservation
loss in particular
they are tied to a few things you need
to have the ability to move your mesh
around obviously
but you also need to be able to have
inter-element jumps
so it means you wouldn't be able to kind
of combine this with the the continuous
galerkin method you'd have to have
like a dg method or a finite volume type
method that supports
those inter-element jumps but with those
two things i i think there's
are other applications that involve
discontinuities that could be
explored okay uh next question is from
pearson uh great talk matt do you have
any
opinions on using cuboid versus
simplicial meshes for this kind of
method
yeah that's a that's a great question so
i've used
only simplex meshes so far and the main
reason
is it's something that i glossed over a
little bit i mentioned it but i glossed
over it was um
when so to do any of the more
complicated
shock structures like those triple
points and things like that
and even the 3d problems that have the
simple stock shock structure you
can't fix the topology of your mesh it's
something that i fought with i wanted to
fix topology of the mesh because i don't
like doing meshing type operations
i wanted to fix the topology of the mesh
for like a year and then eventually just
had to give up on it because you just
can't
really track things if you um if you if
you do that
um at least not complicated things so so
the
the element collapses are critical to be
able to make this work
and the reason that i brought this up is
because element collapses are true i
don't want to say trivial but they're
very
they're easy they're straightforward you
can do them for any polynomial degree
you can do them for any
um dimension like in our code we have a
dimension independent simplex collapse
where it would work in 8d
because of the the the you know known
structure of the of simplex elements
so it's different with hyper cuboids in
general
because if you collapse an edge you're
not guaranteed that the volume goes to
zero so you kind of have to decide what
to do at that point you continue to
collapse edges
until the volume does go to zero do you
try to work with degenerate elements
it's just not obvious exactly how you
would want to handle that
it's something that i'm interested in
doing because a lot of people when i'm
working hypersonics they really like to
use
hexahedral meshes because of um just
they get to give better
approximations to surface heating and
things like that so it's it's something
i definitely
do want to look into but it's more of a
difficult meshing problem
to to remove hypercubes out of your your
cuboids out of your mesh awesome awesome
let me
let me inject my question by the way
there are two more questions but
regarding the element collapse uh in the
context of reduce
your reduced standard of formulation uh
with the shock tracking
yeah probably you don't allow element
collapse there
because right so okay so that's a good
question so
i do allow element collapses to get
our reference mesh right so talk about
how we need a reference domain
so we do implicit shock tracking with
its kind of full
form to get that initial reference mesh
um and then once we do that then you're
right then we don't allow element
collapses to
move to align all of the the different
snapshots
together because then you'd be
collapsing elements and you'd have state
vectors that don't kind of match up
and things so yeah so you you can't
allow it but in but it's a different
problem in that case we're not trying to
align a kind of general unstructured
method with a very specific
discontinuity
we're trying to take that discontinuity
and and push it
right so it's that's why we're kind of
okay freezing the mesh for that step
okay that makes sense okay let's move on
to next question
next question is uh by kevin is there a
way to tie this into time-dependent
problem
yeah um so yes there is and so there's
two different ways to do it
um so the first way that we have a paper
that's on archive right now for the
shock tracking um
version is just using standard method of
lines and where you do that you
replace your you basically just
you pose a shock tracking problem at
each time step
and um and and and you use an ale
formulation to be able to handle the
mesh deformation
and that's that's exactly and you could
you could extend that approach to romps
and so instead of having you know r of u
comma x equals zero
you would have a mass matrix with a u
dot term that you've been you
discretized let's say with
backward euler or wrong cutter or
whatever it happens to be
and then um you use it in that setting
it is inherently built really for
implicit methods though because this
optimization
formulation kind of makes it so you have
to do solves anyway so
it would be hard to justify this with an
explicit
method um i haven't really thought too
much about it other than i i just
don't quite see a way forward with that
but certainly if you're doing an
implicit
method you could do that the way that
but the problem with that though is that
if you have a shock that moves
a large portion of the domain you really
have to have if whatever you
track let's say whatever elements track
the shock at time zero
you kind of have to pull those elements
along the whole way
or you have to do some more complicated
solution transfer
between you know meshes as you as you
kind of pass it off
past the shock off between elements so
what we've done so far is you you would
just track at time
zero or whenever at whatever time the
shock emerges you would do you you do
tracking and then it's the same
edges of the elements the same elements
that track the shock all the time
now of course if the shock moves a lot
then you can really screw up your mesh
so we don't really do the method of
lines approach that much what we
do is we do space time where we just you
know
no matter what you know even if you have
a time term on there you still lump it
inside your
um you just think about the problem in
one higher dimension
and now the time derivative is just one
more dimension in your
your um divergence term and um you you
solve it in space time
and we don't have to do the whole space
time at once the problem that i showed
the sod problem we did we did all of
space time together
but we we're working on approaches we
just do slab by slab by slab
so it kind of looks a lot like time
stepping but you are solving a problem
in one higher dimension
um to do it all albeit over a small
little slab
so those are the two ways that we do
time dependent problems um they both
have their
like if the the method of lines approach
would work meaning your shocks aren't
like doing crazy things bouncing all
over the domain
then that would be the easiest and
probably go-to option
if you have really complicated things
where you have a shock that forms and
then bounces off something and
intersects and goes all the way across
your domain then
i just don't see it really a solid path
forward with the method of lines
so that's why we're we're investing in
in the the slab-based space-time
approach for that
okay sounds good we're related to that
question so how about
how how do you envision you know
extending your method to
turbulent flow or like mixing problems
due to the instability
like yeah so turbulence i haven't
thought too much about turbulent sets um
i it's certainly going to be an issue i
mean the main issue with it is going to
be
um i mean the turbulence is going to
kick up some unresolved features
obviously because of of the the scales
that are involved
so how will the sensor there the
objective function that we have respond
to that
versus discontinuities is not obvious
because it could just
cause the mesh to just freak out during
all these um where all these turbulent
um features are so i'm not sure um
i guess overall but um what i've seen it
i guess it depends on the regime you're
in but shocks are usually significantly
stronger features than
the turbulent vortices and eddies and
things like that
so i still think that we could probably
you know you know
somehow cut off the residual under a
certain when it gets under a certain
point so it kind of ignores the
turbulence
and then still salvage it but yeah
that's something that is a certainly an
area to
to look toward that's a good idea okay
next question is by harshit uh
thanks for the nice talk how how time
consuming is the optimization step
and how do you guide the choice of
regularization parameter gamma
yeah okay so that's a great question so
the optimization step
is more expensive than doing the um
just a standard i mean if you were to
compare it side by side to
you know one step of our sqp thing and
by the way it's the same optimizer that
we use for the rom
settings as the exact same structure we
use the exact same
solver for it one step of that
would be more expensive than one step of
a just a standard you know pseudo
transient continuation or newton solver
without moving the mesh
because you have more degrees of freedom
um so
so yes it's more expensive but where
where it doesn't really affect us that
much
is that um we are using much coarser
meshes
um than you would use if you had to do
this without moving the mesh
so that's kind of where i mean our
meshes depending on how many dimensions
you're in they can be
you know one two or three orders of
magnitude coarser than what you would
need
um and actually it's something that i'm
always i'm not sure if i'm proud of or
embarrassed of that all of the the
results that i showed in
in all of this talk but especially in
the shock tracking section
that was all done with matlab i mean we
were able to do 3d supersonic flow and
over that cylinder in matlab we're able
to do that flow through that scramjet
and matlab and we just use direct
solvers and things so
it's not like they're they're cheap to
do but it's you know because of
how dramatically you can reduce the
number of degrees of freedom needed when
you track shocks
that you you can do these more
complicated problems on
you know not traditionally high
performance computing platforms
um and we are but we are extending it to
you know domain decomposition and and
fully you know full
implicit solvers and things to be able
to push to harder problems
and more complex ones but so so yeah so
the i guess the the summary is
yes they are more expensive but we we
use coarser meshes so it doesn't really
really affect us and then the second
part of the question i guess is how to
regular
choose that regularization parameter
there's a little bit of tuning that goes
involved with that
um but what we we do is we adapt it
actually we have a few different
parameters in here
and and they adapt as they go so for
example this this one is is how we wait
between the mesh
um regularization term and not um and
and we start it
by um not treating the mesh uh what we
we
basically do is we adapt the lambda
parameter such that those two
contributions
are roughly balanced throughout the
optimization
we don't want to let it adapt every
single iteration otherwise it would you
would not be converging you would not be
converging we only allow it to adapt
every you know
at some frequency and then once the
residual drops below a certain value
meaning you're kind of in the convergent
regime
we we disallow the the adaptation of the
parameter
so it's it's it's really it's adapted to
to balance those two terms
and eventually just cut off because we
don't um we don't want it to impede
convergence
okay great thank you matt another
question from
paradip great talk at a high level by
moving the match with solution
in a way a spatial context is provided
in the training for neural network to be
able to better capture the feature of
or dynamic modes despite convection some
works presented at ddps
use the graph techniques to uh provide
spatial
this discretization context for training
can similar graph techniques can be
alternately yeah yeah um
so yeah in one second let me read that
again yeah
provided in the training for neural
network to be
able to better capture the feature or
dynamic modes
despite convection yeah so those i i
didn't do
uh much of a literature review here but
yeah that certainly is a
um a way to do this i mean basically the
main takeaway point here
is that you can't just use
the kind of the standard old linear
basis
approximation if you really want to be
able to
to use limited training and be able to
and and approximate these convection
dominated problems
so ins and somewhat you need to make
your basis non-linear somehow
the way that i chose to make it
non-linear is i composed it
with this domain deformation and that
essentially made for a non-linear
basis there's other ways to do it the
the you know neural network approaches
you know young shoes worked on some
kevin carl brooks worked on some there's
lots of others that have worked on
on these kinds of approaches and that
certainly is an alternative to doing
this that's um you know the this
approach i would say preserves a little
bit of the kind of standard structure
model reduction and we do actually once
we're in the reference domain
we do use a standard linear
approximation
because that's that's the domain where
everything's aligned so that's where we
are using our linear approximation there
so it does preserve a bit of the the
kind of standard model reduction
structure
where you can apply standard hyper
reduction techniques for example
that that you would um you know that
would have to be able to significantly
modify it to fit into the
neural network framework but no you're
you're absolutely right there's there's
this is not
in any means the only way to do this and
there have been other people that have
done so
you know these kind of approaches
tommaso has done those similar
approaches
on has done similar approaches i mean
there's there's there's lots of variants
on these kind of techniques and these
ideas to be able to do convection
dominated
uh problems something in common being
either you know doing some sort of
additivity or somehow making the basis
nominee
right right um all right let me add some
comments
to that i mean um yeah yes i personally
have a research experience of developing
a neural network
solution representation for video
without context
but i do think that uh the maths
you know you know the method he
presented today is
very um advantageous in a sense that the
neural net
you know if you have any experience of
training the neural net it's it's a
a lot of trial and error um procedure
and the training itself can be very
computationally
expensive but on the other hand pod
is very simple like i mean a lot of svd
algorithms
are out there available right for you
and then just
simply you apply this svd and then
getting
you know taking advantage of this the
linear subspace
uh solution representation with
very cheap relatively cheap training
cost
that and then take still use that in the
context of the convex convection
dominated problem
this is this is really really good work
but as as matt mentioned that there are
other
methodology available
okay with that i
don't have any questions from the q and
a's uh
chat i mean chat room but
okay i mean please go ahead and you know
post your question if
at the last minute if you have one but i
just want to
comment one more thing about the maths
that's presentation
you know you mentioned that you know the
model of the reduction can be considered
as a
extreme case of the higher order model i
i really like that comment
actually i yeah i try to
you know advertise that concept of the
modal order reduction within the
lawrence livermore national lab but i i
you know i i was not that successful you
know you know selling
that idea yet but you know external uh
the scholar coming here and then you
know
saying those kind of comments will
definitely help
thank you so much yeah of course okay of
course
all right uh i don't still see the any
questions in the chat room i guess we
can add so on
well matt thank you so much it was very
talk and
i learned a lot and i hope
you will continue to go distraction and
advance you know much more for
for more complicated problem and more
practical and engineering problems
and uh please keep us posted
with uh thanks so much for the
information
i appreciate it yeah no problem and also
i
hope that audiences um this you know
take
advantage of as a like first exposure to
math if you
if you haven't seen matt before uh
please
contact him and then ask question and
email him
i'm sure he's gonna reply to you uh with
a
with a detailed explanation and reply
and
that may that may uh bring up the
collaboration
right right so that's another motivation
for this seminar series
so okay with that let's that's john
and thank you everyone thank you matt
thank you very much all right
okay bye everyone bye